modeling instruction basically kind of
turns things upside-down in the way that
science is opposed in the high school
classroom students are now presented at
the beginning of the unit with basically
a lab experience and tables Q through
five two three five go to one of the
tutorials one of the to one of the four
tutorials in the presenter was some sort
of system that they could have developed
questions about themselves and design
experiments to assess these questions
the data they collect we can then use to
create models that represent not only
the system where them can be generalized
to represent any system that shares
these specific characteristics the idea
is that the students are really
constructing their own understanding
through engaging in this work and the
work tends to be a little bit more
genuine and authentic because it goes to
doing a lab for which theoretically we
should already know the outcome for and
we're just going to calculate a percent
error for so they're actually engaging
in work that scientists are actually
engaging in constructing models